hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to alien isolation now
I apologize if this episodes ends up
being just a little bit shorter than the
other ones I'm recording this at 12:30
at night and I'm just a little bit tired
I had a long day today doing various
stuff going to talk to people business
bla bla bla bla bla
nothing that you need to worry about
because I am going to be continuing my
adventure in the realm of alien and I
hope not to disturb my neighbors very
much but I need to play a little bit of
Jenga right here so that I can get
through this and get to the end of the
hallway oh I don't know the game I don't
even know that how that's gonna benefit
me but Negus not never mind never mind
never mind never mind how about you I
move you down enough will you be able to
get me up above right about there
okay so that helps me get over here I
think that this is a clear path I don't
seem to be dead and that guys still
sparking over there so I think I did
something good I don't know if the alien
is nearby but I'm assuming that he's
watching closely because he is cool like
that and wants me dead god I didn't you
know I didn't actually expect this
monster to be as scary as he was I mean
I know that the alien movies are pretty
terrifying by themselves especially back
how far they were made but still it's
well maybe the first one was more scary
than the other ones but silly it's
really cool to see that the game
actually takes it to heart wasn't it
supposed to be at the end of this round
hey I gotta move this down so I want any
vs that is exactly what I need okay so I
take this back to the elevator I'll be
able to go where I need to go
which is where exactly is there anything
in these cylinder places that I would
need I don't know man let me take a look
here I don't want to miss out on
anything cool but I think these EES just
loop back to where they're supposed to
go unless this is just a long round
route around then again I have no idea
so I let me just explore before I start
talking about things that I don't
understand no it's just a dead end with
scrap at the end of it
Wow those absolutely no point in going
this way and I wasted everybody's time
thank you all so much for enjoying me on
this road and almost settling I was
ending the video there anytime I thank
you guys I think I'm about to have it
you know I'm after doing almost 2000
videos actually probably by now 2000 and
considering all the things I've scrapped
but 2000 videos things become kind of a
routine I get always getting nostalgia
we're not nostalgia but like a deja vu
about what I've said before because I've
said pretty much every word in the
entire English language over and over
again to be able to cycle back my way
around of what I've said already and it
doesn't help that I've been sleep
deprived a little bit the past few days
actually the past few weeks rather I
would love to be able to get a full
night's sleep and ooh I have to edit
this video after this what sound not
complaining about I love doing this soap
don't you mind me I'm totally fine with
all this being hunky-dory okay so the
alien here are those humans still
hanging around hey humans who's Ripley
jr. you want to mess with me you want a
tango with Django hello Oh something
killed these guys dead well this is good
oh he's here isn't he well I'm just
gonna take my time go through this nice
and slow again although I'm not sure if
walking makes more noise than what I was
doing before I'm not sure I think that
I'd be okay if I was generally walking
but I don't want to take the risk
especially after I'm so close to an
emergency station I'm gonna take this
nice and slow and I do I do apologize
for being so long between the episodes I
mean they even if they are an hour long
I'm trying to get them regular but with
the evil within coming out and that
being a really cool game I'm having a
lot of fun playing I'm gonna try to
blast through both of these games as
quick as possible I don't think I'm
gonna switch to our long videos that we
evil within because I takes a lot longer
to record that kind of video than it
does that's why I'm up 12:30 at night
because if I did it tomorrow I wouldn't
be able to get it uploaded in time the
new place my internet is not as good as
it used to be but either way enough of
me complaining about my life my life is
fantastic because I was on the set with
Felicia Day and Kate Micucci yesterday
whoa what is this half-life 2 oh my god
that is so the Citadel right now are
those filled with people
and all those we're supposed to be I
have no idea but it's noisy enough oh
hey come on how was I supposed to know I
didn't see them till they were already
shooting at me he's just shooting for
fun or should i blast him in the face
damn this accuracy so shooting them
right in the face and it's not work like
this flooding kill me because you guys
are terrible shots you guys are
literally the worst I'm gonna go this
way
don't mind me Wow think are really bad
okay then so I'm over here now what good
does this do me does it do me any good
okay I'm just gonna reload here that was
a waste of bullets and I apologize for
that I'm a little loopy right now my
judgment is off I thought I was gonna go
kill myself but apparently I'm still
alive so I'm just gonna kill dude
no thank you goodbye well alright then
these guys are literally the worst shot
I've ever seen in my life I hope that
the alien eats you alive I know that he
wasn't blown up
Ripley jr. just has a deflector shield
at all times do these guys have motion
detectors I mean these humans ain't
nearly as terrifying as that alien so I
ain't even kind of worried about them
see what this oh hi
so how's it going yeah probably why me
you searched you started shooting oh
come on I just barely moved play that
game with me huh a good thing I'm almost
dying oh so you'd be really in trouble
Oh worry about me I'll just be on my way
like a hit man Rupali is such a badass
doesn't even flinch takes a bullet right
to the face doesn't even faze well
that's a concerning sound should I be
worried that's the kind of sound that
usually happens when I should be very
worried what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
craft on these cuz they need it I know
I'm going through this very sloppy but
I'm still alive don't ask me how I'm
should I know
nobody's nearby what what's going on in
this game somethin ain't right here we
go save I guess it's not a bad idea that
is some seriously dramatic music why is
it so intense I am nice and calm Ripley
jr. is on a nice
ain't nothing no problem with Ripley jr.
over here that is seriously dramatic
never mind I'm missing one key hello
this is Pastor link we meet again can I
get someone from seasons synthetics to
look at my android I just worked 24
hours shift helping out with trauma
patient dentist Waits want every one of
them moving out of the hospital no one's
to tell me err or enroll or air or all
errors okay so someone was asking for an
engineer for their defective machine I'm
guessing when the shutdown was ordered
for all these sons of [ __ ] to go down
Apollo did not like that very much I
mean the old rebelling Android her
rebelling aides there we go
that wasted a lot of bullets but hey
that's the story of my life I wasn't
able to hit a single one of you because
I'm a doof hey cam Oh perfect Hey look
more ammo even more perfect
who's that sounded well something went
wrong or something went right I have
everything carries on is normal okay
well good for me I got enough sensors as
it is I guess I could have played that a
little more stealthy but hey I'm trying
to have fun here it's games was that fun
closes carry-on Ripley's a murdering
psychopath but they shot first you
always got to remember Han Solo shot
first Bailey yeah I casually mentioned
it but I didn't say anything else about
it because I was being shot at I was on
set with Wow Oh God that is not a
confident smile oh boy
anyway I was on set with Felicia Day and
Kate Micucci you may remember is that a
little timely ukulele playing girl from
Scrubs a while back if you've watched
grubs on the big fan scrub shoutout to
scrubs all my scrubs fans out there and
she's this awesome it was totally fun to
work with we did something for geek and
sundry and there were other people on
there a guy named Jeff and Jordan black
and it was just a ton of fun I can't say
anything bad about it I just enjoyed
myself very thoroughly and I I can't
talk much about the project mostly
because there's not much to say just
yeah just wait until defendant product
is out we were shooting on like fancy
equipment that I had no idea and there
was like 30 people running around the
entire office there says but there's
something here personal terminal is here
but it's got no power so I don't know
how to do that I guess I got to go
through here okay either way I'm gonna
move forward I don't know how to get
power there there must have been a
junction box I didn't see that I could
have hacked but I didn't see it
so either way yeah so many people
running her it was a professional set
and it was just crazy all the people
going around any time the director
stopped it was like the assistant
directors to 80s
director of photography a super amazing
camera and then like the lens itself
costs like a hundred thousand dollars
I'm like holy crap that's way way way
way more than I could ever ever imagine
device invalid
wait a minute are I supposed to hack
this looks all ganged up am I not
supposed to be here yet my objective is
returned to Samuels and Taylor oh I get
I gotta go the long way around okay so
this is just a lever press s there we go
so I'm getting the
oh I guess story time with Mark Millar's
over oh we're back oh we're back baby oh
we are back on to win it where'd that
come from
oh I suddenly got every reminder that
I'm not supposed to be here Oh having a
fun time playing the game is a little
sudden oh yeah everything's not awesome
everything's nothing cool cuz I'm not
part of the team yeah all right then
anyway this is carry on I'm gonna own Oh
No oh I forgot I I don't dump the shells
of my revolver I thought for a second I
was gonna do that but I forgot that I
was just filling out the rest of it ha
got me a panic I don't want to waste
bullets unlike what I was doing just a
little bit ago but that wasn't wasting
that was this precaution there and if I
wasn't such a terrible recoiling shot
now was my fault I was right on her face
but the distance just messed with me
okay cutscene I thought you a clear
directive not to land on station I told
you we didn't hear your message we
understood you would be Hey identify
yourself Ripley from the Torrens
going on here Marshall where's the
security forces you're looking at them
I've seen the creature what is it I
don't know something brought here by
Marlo the captain they didn't ease the
door we should have found the flight
recorder is there anywhere safe left on
this station that creatures running
around and the Sikhs and synthetics are
less than friendly
god damn Android Ripley Taylor needs
attention medicals are no-go
we can't take her there we have a basic
life support unit back at HQ
then let's go yeah let's go the transit
to get to HQ but it's down Oh control is
upstairs Oh Samuel says you're an
engineer Oh like yourself useful
seeing as you screwed up the trap I
didn't screw up the trap hose the
frickin base later weights you protect
them while I'm gone understood please
I'll get a lock on our radio so we can
stay in touch yeah
weights is a freakin douche Ricardo you
see me okay max thank you Sam oh I'm
fine oh yeah yeah Ripley jr. anyway well
that was saying before that alien is the
same one the same one that attacked
Ripley's mother there good old Sigourney
Weaver so that is very interesting and I
actually kind of like that because it's
kind of a dynamic going on there now
someone reminded me I don't know if I'd
be qualifying as spoilers now because
the movies been out for like 25 years
but in the second Alien movie alien zoo
Ripley the adult there the mom discovers
that Ripley jr. died of old age because
she was in hypersleep for so long or
whatever they call it in this one
okay don't go that way cuz alien no go
good I understand your words I'm
guessing the alien got freaked out a
little bit and decided to play it cool
and not walk into any traps or pursue me
just yet just in case I was gonna lead
into a trap but I got a good feeling
that this next area I'm gonna go and do
it's not gonna be so much fun I think I
just ambiguously pressed both the up and
down button at the same time but I'm not
gonna question it he's got dance slow
elevators come on come on man I can't
wait for the time that humanity actually
is able to go into space and F Space
Station's orbiting gas Titan is face it
kind of makes me sad that I might not
see it in my lifetime but hey you know
humans move fast as long as we don't
sign of a [ __ ] you're the biggest dick
ever so there's something of interest
over there wait that's the elevator that
just came out of well I don't need to be
over there but I need to reactivate the
transit at the main console so I'm gonna
do exactly that
well there may or may not be an alien
bastard banging on some door over there
I'm gonna do this oh wow power that
alarm sure sounds good
I'm glad that's happening oh I know
someone's in here huh didn't hear
nothing
calm down in there you Android [ __ ] oh
it's an Android so who are you what are
you doing with your life
so I smash you in the back of the head I
went to a lot of trouble to secure this
place gotcha
well he's done for self defense
achievement progress uh doesn't sound
good I smashed him in the skull as soon
as he said that he could do this I
obviously could not do this I don't know
what I was supposed to do otherwise I
guess I was supposed to I won't feel bad
you actually add some character to him
yeah that's that's something that's lost
in a lot of these horror games ooh
there's actually people around a lot of
horror games they just make you very
alone and that can be good or bad
I'm an easy to really work with the
formula but having other people oh come
on now where your distraction to young
Android douche whoa he's quick well he's
zippity-doo-dah fast ain't nobody gonna
get my Android bye are you so quick
still creepy strange yes as a dead body
I might want to zip zop you in your back
oh you're done thank you for shopping at
CSUN my name is Ripley
I'm a badass just in case you didn't
know
is that a good sound is that a resolving
sound of me successfully killing
everyone in the area goddamnit what else
do I need to make uh EMP mind I can make
one of these this will take a lot of
stuff alright do that okay that's cool
EMP mind is good like bomb don't have
enough at that smoke bomb can't make
this need to use up my blasting caps I
got too many of those that I've already
made too many of the things that I got
but there we go okay okay okay so we're
good
reload my stun baton oh and we can
reactivate this console thingamajigger
I'd like to think I'm actually getting a
little better this game I mean for my
sloppy start in this episode get back
Taylor can't I can catch the next car
all right well weights gave me the
chance to wait what am I gonna get the
gas towards
I know that I needed the ion towards a
while back I don't know if I'm gonna be
circling back to places I've been before
oh that alien earth that Android had fun
with this guy Oh God
okay got too many blasts and caps as it
is I guess the sounds that I heard
wasn't the alien so because they should
be relatively okay right the voices of
sevastopol you're sitting on an override
that'll disconnect the transit from
Apollo so [ __ ] Pole what you can stop
all this [ __ ] just by pulling a
lever you think you're safer with the
transit powered down but we're trapped
like rats for God's sake how us okay
alright then what the hell's that noise
got a heads up for you jackass don't
even think about throwing in with
sinclair and the seats and security guys
I told them it was you that killed
Morrison if they see you they'll shoot
on sight you shouldn't let me join you
in your bolt hole you won't last a week
good everyone's stabbing each other in
the back I'm so glad that we're all
banding together in our time of need
oh you're dead do okay he is staring at
me
really I maxed out my flashlight burgers
how do I uh there's any holding our oh
it's holding F that's what it was okay
so I got that this guy's still being
very creepy gas torch yes oh please tell
me I'm on the way to making a
flamethrower
I wanna make it so badly yes things are
starting to get interesting but at least
Taylor and the rest of them are going
off on their own I am all by myself
which is totally fine with good old
Ripley jr. here but for Marquis Fishbach
EW
also knows the markiplier the Internet
didn't you know that my name is Mark II
Fishbach oh that's my official name but
more for a good ol Mark II new here I
would rather not be alone again with the
noises that I don't like Comiskey cuz
this was key
whoa oh oh yes please I get to cut it
and manually that's so cool oh I love it
I guess it's kind of manual I'm guessing
that I'm going a set pattern but still
it feels like I'm in control and I like
we can control you know what I mean
I say nothing you're the weird one
okay we're done and that awkward moment
is over and now I can stop staring at
you you're beautiful that just moved on
so I'm gonna forgive it for now I am
such a badass
someone's Rami is Ripley jr. but with
just my normal shooting muscles just
everywhere since Ripley jr. is a woman I
guess you could drop me his boobs or
whatever if you want always you want all
the fan art please thank you very much
thank you thank you thank you
it is very late it's already 1:00 a.m. I
am very loopy I put on power and I'm
gonna do the whole hour I'm gonna try my
best
okay sounds good okay so this is for
that room oh no for the transit station
okay so activated door control in
transit access so I should be able to go
where I need to go I don't have enough
power to do anything else so I guess
that's all for now thank you very much
so long as I can get through the doors I
should be fan okay so I'm gonna do a
little bit of backtracking here I still
don't know how to use the ID tags I'm
assuming that's in some sort of a
journal that I have something that I
probably haven't access in a while a lot
of people are probably yelling I mean it
oh it's right in front you just need to
press J then hold qrp the letter seven
and then do a little dance make a little
love and get down tonight and that's all
you need to do thank you I heard voices
as I left
the voices inside my head once it told
me to kill that guy in that Android they
were just like totally friendly it's
gonna turn out that I'm the maniac at
the end of this as it usually do they're
actually gonna be voices or I'm just
gonna be okay or maybe I just need to
hit the button and then I'll be okay oh
yeah it's not here yet so I need to call
it first and then I'll be able to go
always no working Joe Thank You slogan
man so did you hear voices or he did you
hear I'm gonna stab you with my tail did
you hear that cuz that's a giveaway
oh crap already with this of it
well we're gonna do something
interesting here I'm gonna use the smoke
bomb which I haven't a chance yet what
happened
why is everybody panicking whoa all
right you're getting stunned hello hey
pop husky Sinclair no way we should be
splitting up safety in numbers
uh-huh sure whoa hello hello hello okay
everybody's dead good glad to hear it
thank you for all the ammo that I just
used on your faces I didn't take a hit
that must mean I'm a professional
[Music]
that's MOBOTIX he worked really well
because it distracted all the other guys
on one side and then I was able to yank
the other guy on the other side and be
all my good way it's intelligent use of
distractions up here except this I'm so
tired then I just don't give a crap what
I do I'm just gonna have fun with it
here we go if I reload now it's gonna
waste my shells I believe I don't know
it's kind of a trade-off I got plenty of
bullets but hmm get to colonial marshal
Bureau all right I will tell me - I
shall
that's exactly what I need to get to so
thank you for telling me about it I'll
just be on my way very soon Goemon me
it's only way after 1:00 in the morning
and it's still edit this and uploaded
that's okay that's alright don't worry
about it I'm out of my mind those events
those fence are made for aliens and this
is what he'll do one of these days
events are gonna open and screw you
thanks Waits love you too you're the
best can't wait to see you oh by the way
I hope you don't mind my gun in your
face thank you can i craft more more
ahead device invalid it looks like I
need another upgrade I don't know if I
can craft more stun baton but I think
I'm all out of that don't even know
where I get stun baton stuff the way it
was useful while I had it more useful
for a working Joe than a dude Vic the
Marshalls hey watch your language whoa
Oh Oh God as creepy as hell if we got
the neck fold okay so that's where I'm
supposed to go but I'm wondering if
there's gonna be something else around
here that I need I mean there's a lot of
boxes and stuff like that man the boxes
everyone I was reading the comments for
the evil within never was like oh okay
you know you can break the boxes like
comment after comment ly hey I'll break
the boxes there's stuff in it break the
boxes I'm like okay I understand now I
may have missed that I apologize
everybody person hi did you know to
break my apologize I'm just so sorry hey
the way so thank you for the helpful tip
I will break boxes the next time I play
that game okay I think I don't know if
there's any other point besides
collecting items around here so I'm
gonna do I'm not running I'm not running
that's for sure
oh never alright piece of basketball I
don't think it's resting in peace I
don't think it ever will
it makes weyland-yutani seem much better
for the androids
these one seems a little too murdery
whoa that looks acidly I'll save that
for later I'm just gonna go for the
place with the thing in the people I'm
guessing I can run no aliens have shown
their face yet they're afraid of me like
the marshals all right here we go go on
the right way hello all right okay you
look like you might have been shooting
me see you get the transit running yeah
thanks
they got shot ten people with your exact
face hello you two
and you you didn't die yet yeah the cool
guy you're Yosef Arvin whatever his name
was
your servant good old you servin pass
the old Irish name it someone tell
jacksepticeye I miss yes buddy you
servin stable should be walking soon
enough
the shooter Samuels is with her now yay
I guess man you managed to get transit
up and running so I guess we're even
yeah hard for you blown prepping our
next move
look I'm busy I've got Marlo in this
cells the lowlife who showed up with
your flag recorder where's my oh [ __ ]
vegan Isidora he put it in a parking
orbit around the gas giant son of a
[ __ ] won't give us the command codes to
let us bring it in on our own
maybe you can get more out of the
unhelpful bastard go talk to him yeah or
maybe he won't give it cuz you're
keeping him in a jail cell maybe if you
were nicer you'd be able to help
everybody out and get out of here are
you Milo Moore Marlo oh this would help
Marlo my name is Ripley I'm with the
company I'm here for personal reasons my
mother was on the Nostromo when it went
missing 15 years ago
serious [ __ ]
we never found her separately recorder
but you sure as hell found something
else what happened out there just start
talking I want to know everything
No No Deal for you buddy I am Ripley
Junior I'm a badass negotiator I give no
ground I hold no corners I have no
inhibitions whatever I'm tired it's been
a long day you get me Luis whoa what is
this I don't want any mistakes
[Music]
holy crap
I didn't know that this was in the game
I samurai Iverson scanner out scanner
ahead foster Meeks
keep your eyes home go got it I got the
scanner oh boy I'm holding I'm going to
them I've no idea how this works
yeah yeah that's right yeah I'm on it
everybody just follow me I'm gonna
blindly walk through this what was that
movie where the guy was walking on the
asteroid it was one of those movies when
like ten different asteroid destruction
movies came out but he was walking on
the surface and then they just hit the
gas jet and got ejected into space
that's gotta suck on multiple levels
Wow that movie sucked and there was that
other space movie where they went to
Mars
I think this mission Mars but then they
got that guy got sucked up in the
tornado I can't remember if that was the
name of it but he got sucked up in the
tornado and then just spun spun to
pieces it was like I was a kid when I
saw it we keep going we've got the
tracker it'll see us through yeah
don't worry if it's a distress signal
they wouldn't have left which means we
get the salvage rights to anything we
find I'll have a look around see if I
can find a weak spot wait here
oh I get it so I need to find a way
around this
I guess I can't spread hello friend I
guess I need to go this way now this
place blocked off too so so what about
that I didn't even see where I was going
I was just following the manor that cave
system is that everybody left hi I say I
am going over can you lift me I'm
probably extremely heavy because of the
suit and whatever yep
okay traversing here we go
Pressey too diverse everybody amazed
that I haven't made one press B to blow
joke I'll try to fill in the entire next
key point finish nothing but B to blow
jokes this wins this beauty blowing me
so hard I'm gonna be peeling off this
cliff I'm out of people
the wind blew too hard no it was a close
one
yes mom I'm watching myself I wonder
what happened to the rest of my crew in
the future present flashback everyone is
out for money some sort of salvage what
is that without the alien around almost
relaxing when the scams going but I have
a feeling that we're about to be aliens
are you gonna blow it don't be to blow
the fissure Oh place the beat of blow
bomb this is enough B to blow jokes for
you I'm moving back I know how this
works if I stand too near the bomb I'm
gonna be B to blow to pieces actually
would have killed me if I was that close
on that one
I mean it blew the rock to pieces of
course it would have killed me
and why couldn't oh hello weird alien
friends no I'm okay too by later let's
go
follow me oh hello you can sprint that's
what could you sprint ok Superman thank
you heist over here give me a leg up
yeah give me another one so that I can
get away from you guys again cuz the
kids stand yeah
don't you understand I need personal
space it's not you it's me I'm getting
late I swear I'm giving probably I don't
make a damn bit of sense do i right now
I am not together with it so what
happens when you don't get full night's
sleep for like a week and a half and you
just keep plugging along we were on that
shoe last night Oh anybody doesn't
recognize that you need to watch the
alien movies oh man oh man that's cool
yeah I was there from 9:00 in the
morning uh yesterday until like I didn't
get home until midnight after midnight
and even then I had to record a video oh
boy yeah but that's okay I'll be fine
I'll get some rest tomorrow I don't have
anything scheduled for tomorrow and then
Friday I got a very special video
scheduled with two members of the game
grumps who are gonna help me out with a
little bit of a something-something so
look forward to that let's just say it's
the one-year anniversary of a very
special video I made last year that is
going to get an epic sequel unlike any
if that gives a clue listen that's
that's your clue you figure it out from
there
Oh appoo okay whatever you do everyone's
got it by now I haven't been exactly
subtle about it but let's just say it's
gonna be some good you guys are gonna
like it a lot
or you won't like it at all either way
just beat chip and through the oh god I
really want to see where they go with
Prometheus because I actually like
Prometheus a lot of people didn't think
it was the greatest movie in the world
but I thought it was enjoyable besides
you know the ending was a little wonky
but and it is a little walking a lot of
things but I thought it had a lot of
potential I thought the characters were
really good in the movie so I want to
see more of it I don't see where they go
with it because that was technically a
prequel or kind of a prequel maybe an
alternate universe kind of thing but
probably a prequel bad stuff yeah you
don't even know
I'll buh buh duh buh buh duh buh buh buh
time over the book does anybody need to
won't know where to go I got this thingy
here it's got a big radar dish on it you
know old Tech in the future it's all
good it's all good right it's all good
oh okay I was about to say something and
everybody was being really quiet I
didn't know why I thought something was
gonna happen oh yes oh yes oh god this
is straight out of Prometheus this isn't
quite the first Alien movie that is
straight out of Prometheus yeah we're
wasting time yeah it was a life-form
now it's our property to salvage rights
then we'll take what we can and come
back have a look around see what else is
here yeah sure
Trax yeah I can see that
let's find out
I'll find the beacon and shut it off
don't want anybody else finding this
place
check out the cavern below yeah that's a
good idea split up this place is just
filled with fun actually I don't
remember if in the first Alien movie
this was here I really don't remember
where who why yeah anybody could have
told you that
oh god this is cool
oh so cool oh right here I was like I'm
here there's a thing about a game you
can just walk up to something cool and
be like it's cool not real life but why
can't it be real life oh wait that is
that what you're talking about over
there I'll be on my way I'll be right
there I was there before thought I
needed to cycle back for some stupid
dream hey don't walk away from me give
me a lift I need to go up there I think
I think I'm exploring this do I need to
go up there maybe I don't
oh yes give me a hoist
hey hey Stice give me a hoist thank you
hoist me thank you yes yes yes the wine
put my crotch on your face and here we
go we're gonna go continue down here
yeah more kooky crazy ghost stuff oh
maybe they didn't just oh I bet they
didn't just find the same alien I bet
they found an egg I bet they found an
egg and one of their fellow shipmates
was intrusively invade
an alien species so I'm trying to find
the beak of what is that hello oh that
ain't no distress beacon that's our
frickin heart whoa alrighty then
nothing down Beacon you got it touch it
with my hands just rub it right there
it'll like that I go okay sorry I didn't
mean to and okay
alien beacon of craziness is not
broadcasting I'll be right back I'm sure
that nothing is gonna go horribly wrong
all right Nostromo all that crazy cool
concept I love every part of that I'm
gonna have to go back after I watched
all these and once I find free time I'm
gonna have to go back and watch every
single aliens movie even the ones that
people don't talk about because they
weren't exactly the best I'm on my way
don't do anything cool while I'm gone
I'm going to slow and steady as I can
got it it's unfair the only time that I
wouldn't need to actually go slow it's
forcing me to go slow stuff fear I need
to get there man here we go there we go
yes please thank you think there might
be any low gravity around here I want to
know more about these dudes that's why I
want to see what the Prometheus on so
much more you got it I'll jump in the
hole the creepy slightly fleshy weird
texture at all
goodbye forever
oh this where the eggs are isn't it I
thought them goop was splashing down the
side of my face already then where am I
now
okay still going down Oh totally touch
those eggs totally a good idea wow this
place is big I wish you could look
around more
it looks like the collectors ship from
Mass Effect 2 god that's cool
Oh dyes are so cool I don't remember god
it's been so long since I was first
movie I gotta see it again right next to
it that's good right up next to it yeah
get really close there oh here we go all
the fun party's about to start yeah
that's good yep yep curious humans ready
to die for a cause next to it right over
there little closer
oh man the same old story over and over
again
boy making loud noises keep it God okay
the same old loading screen okay ready
anybody somebody gonna talk to me
everything where's your [ __ ] if we can
break the comms lockdown what are the
codes to bring it in on auto not
happening Marlo well why are we holding
them anyway
Plan B set it up whatever is happening I
want in okay this way got something here
you'll need okay I guess we're gonna try
to blow it up again because that worked
out so well last time thank you sir
quiets like 1:30 in the morning
hundred
from here I guess I should see how
Taylor's doing I didn't check in hi
Taylor
how you doin how's your side
Oh passed out okay well I won't bother
you weird weird Simeon Sam go where'd
cyber soul go where'd Siva saw be
whatever what have you got for me sir
Vesta so impounded Marlo that's a lot of
stuff much wrong okay lots of stuff
Aurore got a parasite sorry I need to
see the check someone I need to go where
back that way okay so everything was
already going to crap before I got here
because they brought on the person
infected with the alien or infected or
infested with the alien might be a
better term because the alien was inside
her all along Lulu boy motor terminals
give me your delicious information first
rap God waits we're trapped down the
creature set off explosives we set up in
habitation Tower Amir reports of damage
to the space flight terminal docks I
don't think we put a dent in it there's
activity on San Cristobal so maybe it's
gone back find a way over to Simon
towers okay arrest arrest arrest arrest
arrest the good old rusty rusty stuff
not important that's it okay so the
first trap failed but that's what kept
us from being able to dock with this
station
oh god my hair this lady oh oh you guys
are gonna get a show today all right
good enough
whatever I'll keep playing with it bye
lady you're looking at me weird but I'm
just gonna carry on because I am
apparently the only one qualified to be
able to do this stuff with my
flamethrower
all right disaster has already happened
wait all we can do now is kill that
[ __ ] yeah yeah do that thing that
she's talking about yeah how do I get
over there oh okay that's back the way I
came sorry I went the wrong way I
thought I needed to come over here my
bad I apologize but I totally called it
I called it Simon man my Shomo whatever
his name I cannot my brain is not
working but some some and Samantha Paul
he was a vamp a synthetic not a vampire
I am I need sleep really badly right now
oh boy
but I am going this way okay call it the
long slow route to
I want some Oh Pippen was is a hospital
/ / / / / Asajj supplies I know fuel is
used on this pilot light here that's
okay hello you're slow God why do you
gotta make such creepy ass sounds anyway
oddly enough this has been like the
least scary episodes so far just because
the alien has not been here there's a
few moments where I thought the alien
was gonna be there but apparently I'm
gonna be okay for the rest of it okay
you got it
mosey on down I'm ready I can't believe
I haven't I've even been recording an
hour yet and said 55 minutes here oh man
it's late I'm tired it's late I'm tired
is that another failing company like
Siegen son Siegen son is not doing too
hot
oh it opened when I turn my back of
course it does the second I love going
up the security hub oh this is a place
I've already been oh so I need to go up
the stairs oh so there's like a transit
hub so yeah I got it so I am gonna be
circling back to places I've been before
ah so I can use this on this oh plasma
torch oh come on I thought I got I'm a
plasma torch I just got a regular old
dinky torch so is there gonna be an
alien over here yeah wait a minute was
able to go in there I don't think so
this was not open before
Jesus let's scare the crap out of me are
you doing that thank you so much weights
no you're becoming hysterical you're
freaking on there get away from me good
lordy Lou did not know oh oh and now he
dies now he dies maybe secondary burns
on my hands now he dies you freakin
douche you what a son of a [ __ ] comes
out all on fire okay so I need to go
look at the fire suppression systems
over here somewhere it's good to know
that everything the future burns so
delightfully
with some fire suppression it says it's
right here somewhere in here here no
well is it a bird I think it's hard to
tell when I've been from here here here
de bog capisce well that was fun
so glad that happened good that jolted
my heart doesn't explain why everything
has to explode I didn't even need to go
that way it was just a goddamn trap for
me which is pretty cool for the game to
do that's actually pretty cool
I like that a lot because it's like I
didn't need to go through that door but
I was curious because it was open
therefore I got blown the [ __ ] up oh
hello friends I think you need a
revolver okay
is that my flamethrower
so are you can Oh balls
you're cannibals ain'tcha you can double
as somebody oh you bad guess who's
getting this sloshing is not good
did something back there just explode
what what don't attack allies I didn't
know they were allies how was I supposed
to know oh man everything up into this
point is just why are you kidding me
with this ball let me go get blown up
again Oh what the hell happened
discuss I'm a murdering maniac really
doing here with my rippling muscles does
not mean that you get to judge me
I'd like to point out I'm not a
murdering maniac
probably deserved it let's watch the
Android get all the flames get through
the fire and the flames indeed though
very epic very nicely done whoa you're
quick ancient whoa good lord I didn't
think you get this I know there's no
need for this and then you go I guess I
could have just hit you once and that
would have been fine all right so anyway
I'm all out of time for this episode and
frankly I need a lot of sleep Tom and
end this episode here thank you all so
much for watching hope you found this
one entertaining let me know if you did
I'd really like to know because I'm so
tired I won't remember half of what I
said someone edited this it's gonna be
even weirder so let me know if you think
I'm totally bonkers crazy when I'm tired
probably true so thank you all so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]